السلام
[Silence]
‏make
trash there sp let us we can clean up sp
there
people keeping
[Silence]
الله اكبر الله
اكبر اشهد ان اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول
الله حي على
الصلاه حي على
الفلاح قد قامت
الصلاه قد قامت
الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله استقيم واعتدلوا استووا سووا الصف
سدوا
الخلل
الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين حرمت عليكم
امهاتكم وبناتكم واخواتكم
وعماتكم
وخالاتكم
وخالاتكم وبنات الاخ وبنات الاخت
وامهاتكم وامهاتكم
التلاتي ارضعنكم
واخواتكم من
الرضاعه
وامهات
نسائكم
واخواتكم من الرضاعه
وامهات
نسائكم
وربائبكم
اللاتي في حجوركم من
نسائكم اللاتي دخلتم
بهن فان لم تكونوا دخلتم بهن فلا جناح
عليكم
وحلائل
ابنائكم الذين من
اصلابكم وان تجمعوا بين متين الا ما قد
سلف ان الله كان غفورا
رحيما والمحصنات من
النساء الا ما ملكت
ايمانكم كتاب الله عليكم واحل لكم ما وراء
ذلكم ان تبتغوا
تبتغوا
باموالكم محصنين غير
مسافحين فما
استمتعتم به منهن
فاتوهن
اجورهن
فريضه ولا جناح عليكم فيما تراضيتم به من
بعد
الفريضه ان الله كان ع عليما
حكيما الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين ومن لم يستطع منكم طولا ان ينكح
المحصنات المؤمنات
فمما فمما ملكت
ايمانكم من
فتياتكم
المؤمنات والله اعلم
بايمانكم بعضكم من
بعض
فانكحوهن باذن اهلهن
واتوهن
اجورهن
اجورهن بالمعروف محصنات غير
مسافحات ولا متخذات
اخدان فاذا احصن فان اتين
بفاحشه فعليهن نصف ما على المحصنات من
العذاب ذلك لمن خشي العنه
منكم وان تصبروا خير لكم والله غفور
رحيم يريد الله ليبين لكم ويهديكم سنن
الذين من قبلكم ويتوب
عليكم والله عليم
حكيم والله الله يريد ان يتوب
عليكم ويريد الذين يتبعون الشهوات ان
تميلوا ميلا
عظيما يريد الله ان يخفف
عنكم وخلق
الانسان
ضعيفا الله اكبر
سيع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله اكبر
سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
استقيموا اعتدلوا
استووا سووا الصف سد
الخلل
الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا
الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
يا ايها الذين امنوا لا تاكلوا اموالكم
بينكم بالباطل
الا الا ان تكون تجاره عن تراض
منكم ولا تقتلوا انفسكم ان الله كان بكم
رحيما ومن يفعل ذلك عدوانا و ظلما فسوف
نصليه نارا وكان ذلك على الله
يسيرا ان تجتنبوا
كبائر ما تنهون عنه نكفر عنكم
سيئاتكم نكفر عنكم سيئاتكم
وندخلكم مدخلا
كريما ولا تتمنوا ما فضل الله به بعضكم
على بعض للرجال نصيب مما اكتسبوا
وللنساء نصيب مما
اكتسب واسالوا الله من فضله ان الله كان
بكل شيء
عليما ولكل جعلنا موالي مما ترك الوالدان
والاقربون
والذين عقدت ايمانكم فاتوهم
نصيبهم ان الله كان على كل شيء
شهيدا الرجال قوامون على
النساء بما
فضل الرجال قوامون على
النساء بما فضل الله بعضهم على بعض وبما
انفقوا من
اموالهم فالصالحات قانتات حافظات للغيب
بما حفظ
الله واللاتي تخافون نشوزهن
فعظوهن
واهجروهن في
المضاجع واهجروهن في المضاجع
واضربوهن فان طعنكم فلا تبغوا عليهن
سبيلا ان الله كان عليا
كبيرا وان خفتم شقاق بينهما فبعثوا حكما
من اهله وحكما من
اهلها ان يريدا اصلاحا يوفق الله
بينهما ان الله كان علي
خبيرا واعبدوا الله ولا تشركوا به شيئا
وبالوالدين
احسانا وبذي القربى واليتامى والمساكين
والجار ذي القربى والجار الجنب والصاحب
بالجنب والصاحب بالجنب وابن السبيل وما
ملكت ايمانك
ان الله لا يحب من كان مختالا
فخورا الذين يبخلون ويامرون الناس بالبخل
ويكتمون ويكتمون ما اتاهم الله من فضله
واعتدنا
للكافرين عذابا
مهينا وال الذين ينفقون اموالهم
رئاء الناس ولا يؤمنون بالله واليوم
الاخر ومن يكن الشيطان له قرينا
فساء
قرينا وماذا عليهم لو امنوا بالله واليوم
الاخر وانفقوا
وانفقوا مما رزقهم
الله وكان الله بهم
عليما الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال
ضالين
امين
ان الله لا يظلم مثقال ذره وان تك حسنه
يضاعفها ويؤت من لدنه اجرا
عظيما فكيف اذا جئنا من كل امه بشهيد
وجئنا بك على
هؤلاء
شهيدا يومئذ يود الذين كفروا وعصوا الرسول
لو تسوى بهم الارض لو تسوى بهم الارض ولا
يكتمون الله
حديثا يا ايها الذين امنوا لا تقربوا
الصلاه و انتم سكارى حتى تعلموا ما
تقولون ولا جنبا الا عابري سبيل حتى
تغتسلوا وان كنتم مرضى او على سفر او جاء
احد منكم من
الغائط او جاء احد منكم
من
الغائط او لامستم
النساء ولم تجدوا
ماء ف ولم تجدوا
ماء
فتيمموا صعيدا
طيبا فلم تجدوا
ماء
فتيمموا صعيدا طيبا
فامسحوا بوجوهكم
وايديكم ان الله كان عفوا
غفورا الم تر الى الذين اوتوا نصيبا من
الكتاب يشترون الضلاله
ويريدون يشترون الضلاله ويريدون ان تضل
السبيل والله اعلم باعداء
م وكفى بالله وليا وكفى بالله
نصيرا من الذين هادوا يحرفون الكلم عن
مواضعه
ويقولون ويقولون سمعنا وعصينا واسمع غير
مسمع
وراعنا وراعنا ليا بالسنتهم وطعنا في
الدين ولو انهم قالوا سمعنا واطعنا واسمع
وانظرنا لكان خيرا لهم
واقوم ولكن لعنهم الله بكفرهم فلا يؤمنون
الا
قليلا يا ايها الذين ام يا ايها الذين
امنوا امنوا بما نزل
يا ايها الذين اوتوا الكتاب امنوا بما
نزلنا مصدقا لما
معكم من قبل ان نطمس وجوها فنردها على
ادبارها او نلعنهم كما لعنا اصحاب السبت
وكان امر الله مفعولا
ان الله لا يغفر ان يشرك به ويغفر ما دون
ذلك لمن
يشاء ومن يشرك بالله فقد افترى اثما
عظيما الم تر الى الذين يزكون
انفسهم بل الله يزكي من يشاء
ولا يظلمون
فتيلا انظر كيف كذبوا على
انفسهم انظر كيف يفترون على الله
الكذب وكفى به اثما
مبينا الم تر الى الذين اوتوا الكتا الم
تر الى
الذين الم تر الى الذين اوتوا الكتاب
يشترون
الضلاله الم تر الى الذين اوتوا نصيبا من
الكتاب
يقولون الم تر الى الذين اوتوا نصيبا من
الكتاب يؤمنون بالجبت والطاغوت
ويقولون ويقولون للذين كفروا
هؤلاء اهدى من الذين امنوا
سبيلا
اولئك الذين لعنهم
الله ومن يلعن الله فلن تجد له
نصيرا ام لهم نصيب من الملك فاذا لا يؤتون
الناس
نقيرا ام يحسدون
الناس على ما اتاهم الله من فضله فقد
اتينا ال ابراهيم الكتاب والحكمه
واتيناهم ملكا
عظيما فمنهم من امن به ومنهم من صد عنه
وكفى
بجهنم
سعيرا ان الذين كفروا باياتنا سوف نصليهم
نارا سوف نصليهم نارا كلما نضجت جلودهم
بدلناهم جلودا غيرها ليذوق ليذوقوا
العذاب ان الله كان عزيزا
حكيما والذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
سندخلهم سندخلهم
جنات تجري من تحتها الانهار خالدين
فيها لهم
فيها ازواج
مطهره خالدين فيها ابدا لهم فيها ازواج
مطهره
وندخلهم ظلا ظلي
الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكب
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
الله
اكبر بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
ان الله يامركم ان تؤدوا الامانات الى
اهلها واذا حكمتم بين الناس ان تحكموا
بالعدل ان الله نعما يعظكم به ان الله كان
سميعا
بصيرا يا ايها الذين امنوا اطيعوا الله
واطيعوا الرسول واولي الامر
منكم فان تنازعتم في شيء فردوه الى الله
والرسول ان
كنتم ان كنتم تؤمنون بالله واليوم
الاخر ذلك خير واحسن
تاويلا الم تر الى الذين اوتوا نصيبا من
الكتاب
يؤمنون الم تر الى الذين اوتوا نصيبا من
الكتاب يؤ الم تر الى الذين
اوتوا الم تر الى الذين اوتوا نصيبا من
الكتاب يؤمنون بما انزل اليك وما زل من
قبلك الم تر الى الذين يزعمون انهم يؤمنون
بما انزل اليك وانزل من قبلك
يريدون ويريدون ان يتحاكموا الى الطاغوت
وقد امروا ان يكفروا
به ويريد الشيطان ان يضلهم ضلالا بعي دا
اولئك هم الكافرون
حقا
واعتدنا للكافرين عذابا
اليما ولو انهم
قال الم تر الى الذين يزعمون انهم امنوا
بما انزل اليك وما انزل من قبلك
يريدون يريدون ان يتحاكموا الى الطاغوت
وقد امروا ان يكفروا
به ويريد الشيطان ان يضلهم ضلالا
بعيدا
اولئك هم المنافقون
حقا واذا قيل لهم ت واذا قيل لهم تعالوا
الى ما انزل الله الى
الرسول رايت المنافقين يصدون عنك
صدودا فكيف اذا اصابتهم مصيبه بما قدمت
ايديهم ثم
جاؤوك يحلفون بالله ان اردنا احسانا
وتوفيقا ان اردنا الا احسانا
وتوفيقا ولو انهم
جا ولو انهم اذ ظلموا انفسهم جاؤوك
فاستغفروا الله فاستغفروا الله واستغفر
لهم الرسول لوجدوا الله توابا
رحيما اولئك الذين يعلم الله ما في قلوب
فاعرض عنهم وعظهم وقل لهم في انفسهم قولا
بليغا وما ارسلنا من رسول الا ليطاع باذن
الله ولو انهم اذ ظلموا انفسهم
جاؤوك فاستغفروا الله فاستغفروا الله
واستغفر لهم الرسول لوجدوا الله
لوجدوا الله توابا
رحيما فلا وربك لا يؤمنون حتى يحكموك فيما
شجر
بينهم ثم لا يجدوا في انفسهم حرجا مما
قضيت
ويسلموا
تسليما ولو انا كتبنا عليهم ان اقتلوا
انفسكم او اخرجوا من دياركم ما فعلوه الا
قليل منهم ولو انهم فعلوا ما يوعظون به
لكان خيرا لهم واشد
تثبيتا واذا
لاتيناهم من لدنا اجرا عظيما ولهديناهم
صراطا
مستقيما ومن يطع
والرسول
فاولئك مع الذين انعم الله عليهم
فاولئك مع الذين انعم الله
عليهم من النبيين
والصديقين
والشهداء
والشهداء والصالحين وحسن اولئك
رفيقا ذلك الفضل من الله وكفى بالله
عليما يا ايها الذين امنوا خذوا حذركم
فانفروا ثبات او انفروا
جميعا وان منكم لمن ليبطئن
فان اصابتكم
مصيبه قال قد انعم الله علي اذ لم اكن
معهم
شهيدا ولئن اصابكم فضل من الله
ليقولن
ليقولن ك ان لم تكن بينكم وبينه
موده يا ليتني كنت معهم
فافوز فوزا
عظي الله اكبر
سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الد الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين فليقاتل في سبيل الله الذين يشر
يشترون الذين يشرون الحياه الدنيا
بالاخره ومن يقاتل في سبيل الله فيقتل او
يغلب فسوف نؤتيه اجرا
عظيما وما لكم لا تقاتلون في سبيل الله
والمستضعفين من الرجال
والنساء والولدان الذين يقولون
الذين يقولون ربنا اخرجنا من هذه القريه
الظالم
اهلها واجعل لنا من لدنك وليا واجعل لنا
من لدنك
نصيرا الذين امنوا يقاتلون في سبيل
الله والذين كفروا يقاتلون في سبيل
الطاغوت
فقاتلوا
اولياء الشيطان ان كيد الشيطان كان
ضعيفا الم تر الى الذين قيل لهم كفوا
ايديكم واقيموا الصلاه واتوا
الزكاه فلما كتب عليهم القتال اذا فريق
منهم يخشون الناس كخشية
وقالوا ربنا لم كتبت علينا
القتال وقالوا ربنا لم كتبت علينا القتال
لولا اخرتنا الى اجل
قريب قل متاع الدنيا قليل والاخره خير لمن
اتقى ولا تظلمون
فتيلا اينما تكون كونوا يدرككم الموت ولو
كنتم في بروج
مشيده وان تصبهم حسنه يقولوا هذه من عند
الله وان تصبهم سيئه يقولوا هذه من
عندك قل
كل من عند
الله فما لهؤلاء
القوم لا يكادون يفقهون
حديثا ما اصابك من
حسنه فمن الله وما اصابك من
سيئات فمن نفسك وارسلناك للناس رسولا وكفى
بالله
شهيدا من يطع الله فقد اطاع من يطع الرسول
فقد اطاع
الله ومن تولى فما ارسلناك عليه
حفيظا ويقولون طاعه فاذا برزوا من عندك
بيه
طائفه منهم غير الذي
تقول والله يكتب ما
يبيتون فاعرض عنهم وتوكل على الله وكفى
بالله
وكيلا افلا
يتدبرون
القران ولو كان من عند غير الله لوجدوا
فيه
اختلافا
كثيرا واذا
جاءهم امر من الامن او الخوف اذاعوا به
ولو ردوه الى الرسول والى اولي الامر منهم
لعلمه الذين
يستنبطونه
منهم ولولا فضل الله عليكم ورحمته لاتبعتم
الشيطان الا
قليلا فقاتل في سبيل الله لا تكلف الا
نفسك وحرض
المؤمنين عسى الله ان يكف الذين
كفروا والله اشد
باسا واشد
تنكيلا من يشفع شفاعه حسنه يكن له كفل
منها ومن يشفع من يشفع شفاعه حس من يشفع
شفاعه حسنه يكن له نصيب منها
ومن يشفع
شفاعه سيئه يكن له كفل
منها وكان الله على كل شيء
مقيتا واذا
حييتم
بتحيه فحيوا باحسن
منها فحيوا باحسن منها او
ردوها ان الله الله كان على كل شيء
حسيبا الله لا اله الا و
ليجمعنكم الى يوم القيامه لا ريب
فيه ومن اصدق من الله
حديثا الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكب
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الحمد لله الحمد لله والصلاه والسلام على
رسول الله وعلى اله وصحبه ونولا ومن تبع
باحسان الى يوم
الدين ‏as i mention prev
[Silence]
قران الله سبحانه وتالق شهر رمضان الذ انز
فيه
القران
[Silence]
رمضان رول اللهصلى علسلم
بخاري رسول الله صل علسلم عليه الصلاه
والسلام خيركم تعلم القران وعلمه
‏teach other people
jar حول
‏from
[Silence]
‏let my
الله
[Silence]
how commitment few
daily not asking you entire
‏trans
and
from
all chapter
take
of le
حول اللهصلى
الله الله سبحانه وتالى اللهم اجعل قران
ربي قلوبنا وجل احزاننا وذهاب همومنا
وغمومنا ربنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي
الاخره حسنه وك عذاب النار وكنا عذاب
القبر وكنا عذاب جنم وكنا شتنا محيا
الممات وكنا ش فتنه المسيح الدجال ربنا
تقبل منا انك السميع العليم وتوب علينا يا
مولان تواب الرحيم وصلى الله على محمد
وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين برحمتك يا ارحم
الراحمين اللهم امين اللهم امين اللهم
امين
[Silence]
استووا
واعتدلوا
استو
الله اكبر
بسم
الله الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين الله لا اله الا هو
ليجمعنكم الى يوم القيامه لا ريب
فيه ومن اصدق من الله
حديثا فما لكم في المنافقين فئتين والله
اركسهم بما كسبوا اتريدون ان تهدوا من اضل
الله ومن يضلل الله فلن تجد له سبيلا ودوا
لو تكفرون كما كفروا فتكونون
سواء فلا تتخذوا منهم
اولياء حتى يهاجروا في سبيل
الله فان تولوا فخذوا واقتلوهم حيث
وجدتموهم ولا تتخذوا منهم وليا ولا
نصيرا الا الذين يصلون الى قوم بينكم
وبينهم ميثاق او
جاؤوكم حصرت صدورهم ان يقاتلوكم او
يقاتلوا
قومهم ولو شاء الله لسلطهم عليكم فلقات
لوكم
فان اعتزلوكم فلم يقاتلوكم والقوا اليكم
السلم فما جعل الله لكم عليهم
سبيلا ستجدون اخرين يريدون ان يامنو ويامن
قومهم كلما ردوا الى الفتنه اركسوا
فيها فان لم يعتزل ويلقوا فان لم يعتزل
ويلقوا
فان لم يعتزل ويلقوا اليكم السلم ويكفوا
ايديهم فخذوهم واقتلوهم حيث ثقفتموهم
واولئك جعلنا لكم عليهم سلطانا
مبينا وما كان لمؤمن ان يقتل مؤمنا الا
خطا ومن قتل مؤمنا خطا فتحرير رقبه مؤمنه
وديه مسلمه الى اهله الا ان
يصدقوا فان كان من قوم عدو لكم وهو مؤمن
فتحرير رقبه
مؤمنه وان كان من قوم بينكم وبينهم ميثاق
فديه مسلمه الى اهله وتحرير رقبه
مه فمن لم يجد فصيام شهرين متتابعين توبه
من
الله وكان الله عليما
حكيما ومن يقتل
مؤمنا
متعمدا فجزاؤه
جهنم خالدا
فيها وغضب الله عليه ولعنه واعد له عذابا
عظيما يا ايها الذين امنوا اذا ضربتم في
سبيل الله فتبينوا ولا تقولوا لمن القى
اليكم السلام لست مؤمنا
تبتغون تبتغون عرض الحياه الدنيا
فعند الله مغانم
كثيره كذلك كنتم من قبل فمن الله عليكم
فتبينوا ان الله كان بما تعملون
خبيرا لا يستوي القاعدون من المؤمنين غير
اولي الضرر
والمجاهدون في سبيل الله باموالهم
وانفسهم فضل الله المجاهدين باموالهم
وانفسهم على الق ين درجه وكلا وعد الله
الحسنى وفضل الله المجاهدين على القاعدين
اجرا
عظيما
درجات منه ومغفره ورحمه وكان الله غفورا
رحيما ان الذين توفاهم
الملائكه ظالمي انفسهم
قالوا فيما
كنتم قالوا كنا مستضعفين في الارض قالوا
الم تكن ارض الله واسعه فتهاجروا فيها
فاولئك ماواهم جهنم وساءت
مصيرا الا المستضعفين من الرجال
والنساء والولدان لا يستطيعون حيله ولا
يهتدون
سبيلا فاولئك عسى الله ان يعفو عنهم وكان
الله عفوا
غفورا الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ومن يهاجر في سبيل الله يجد في الارض
مراغما كثيرا وسعه ومن يخرج من بيته
مهاجرا الى الله ورسوله ثم يدركه الموت
فقد وقع اجره على
الله وكان الله غفورا
رحيما واذا ضربتم في الارض فليس عليكم
جناح ان تقصروا من الصلاه ان خفتم ان
يفتنكم الذين كفروا ان الكافرين كانوا لكم
عدوا
مبينا واذا كنت فيهم فاقمت لهم الصلاه
فلتقم
طائفه منهم معك ولياخذوا
اسلحتهم فاذا سجدوا فليكونوا من ورائكم
ولت طائفه
اخرى لم يصلوا فليصلوا معك ولياخذوا حذرهم
واسلحتهم ود الذين كفروا لو تغفلون عن
اسلحتكم وامتعت فيميلون عليكم
ميله
واحده ولا جناح عليكم ان كان بكم اذى من
مطر او كنتم مرضى ان ضعوا
اسلحتكم وخذوا حذركم ان الله اعد للكافرين
عذابا
مهينا فاذا قضيتم الصلاه فاذكروا الله
قياما وقعودا وعلى جنوبكم فاذا
اطمئنت فاقيموا
الصلاه ان الصلاه كانت على المؤمنين كتابا
قوتا ولا تهنوا في ابتغاء القوم ان تكونوا
تالمون فانهم يالمون كما تالمون وترجون من
الله ما لا
يرجون وكان الله عليما
حكيما انا انزلنا اليك الكتاب بالحق لتحكم
بين الناس بما اراك الله
ولا تكن
للخائنين خصيما واستغفر الله ان الله كان
غفورا
رحيما ولا تجادل عن الذين يختانون
انفسهم ان الله لا يحب من كان خوانا
اثيما يستخفون من الناس ولا يستخفون من
الله وهو معهم اذ يبيتون ما لا يرضى من
القول وكان الله بما يعملون
محيطا ها انتم
هؤلاء جادلتم عنهم في الحياه الدنيا فمن
يجادل الله عنهم يوم
القيامه
امن يكون عليهم
وكيلا ومن يعمل س
او يظلم نفسه ثم يستغفر الله يجدي الله
غفورا
رحيما ومن يكسب اثما فانما يكسبه على نفسه
وكان الله عليما
حكيما ومن يكسب
خطيئه او اثما ثم يرم به
بريئا فقد احتمل بهتانا واثما مبينا
ولولا فضل الله عليك ورحمته لهم
الطائفه منهم ان يضلوك وما يضلون الا
انفسهم وما يضرونك من
شيء
وانزل الله عليك الكتاب والحكمه وعلمك ما
لم تكن تعلم وكان فضل الله عليك
عظيما الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر السلام عليكم رحمه الله السلام عليكم
رحمه الله
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين لا خير في كثير من نجواهم الا من امر
بصدقه او معروف او اصلاح بين
الناس ومن يفعل ذلك ابتغاء مرضاه الله
فسوف نؤتيه اجرا
عظيما ومن يشاقق الرسول من بعد ما تبين له
الهدى ويتبع غير سبيل المؤمنين نوله ما
تولى ونصله
جهنم ونصله جهنم وساء
مصيرا ان الله لا يغفر ان يشرك به ويغفر
ما دون ذلك لمن
يشاء ومن يشرك بالله فقد ضل ضلالا
بعيدا ان يدعون من دونه الا
اناثا وان يدعون الا شيطانا
مريدا لعنه
الله وقال لاتخذن من عبادك نصيبا مفروضا
ولاضلنهم
ولامنينهم
ولامرنهم
فليبتكن اذان
الانعام
ولامرنهم
فليغيرن خلق
الله ومن يتخذ الشيطان وليا من دون الله
قد خسر خسرانا
مبينا يعدهم
ويمنيهم وما يعدهم الشيطان الا
غرورا اولئك ماواهم جهنم ولا يجدون عنها
محيصا والذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
سندخلهم جنات تجري من تحتها
الانهار خالدين فيها ابدا وعد الله حقا
ومن اصدق من الله
قيلا ليس بامانيكم ولا اماني اهل
الكتاب من يعمل سوء ان يجز به ولا يجد له
من دون الله وليا ولا
نصيرا ومن يعمل من الصالحات من ذكر او
انثى وهو مؤمن فاولئك يدخلون الجنه ولا
يظلمون
نقيرا ومن احسن دينا ممن اسلم وجهه لله
وهو محسن واتبع مله ابراهيم حنيفا واتخذ
الله ابراهيم
خليلا ولله ما في السماوات وما في الارض
وكان الله بكل ل شيء
محيطا ويستفتونك في
النساء قل الله يفتيكم فيهن وما يتلى
عليكم في الكتاب في يتامى
النساء
اللاتي وما يتلى عليكم في الكتاب في يتامى
النساء ال تي لا تؤتونهن ما كتب لهن
وترغبون ان تنكحوهن
والمستضعفين من الولدان وان تقوموا
لليتامى
بالقسط وما تفعلوا من خير فان الله كان به
عليما وان امراه خافت من بعلها نشوزا او
اعراضا فلا جناح عليهما ان يصلحا بينهما
صلحا والصلح خير واحضرت
الانفس
الشح وان تحسنوا وتتقوا فان الله كان بما
تعملون
خبيرا وان تحسنوا وتتقوا فان الله كان بما
خبيرا ولن تستطيعوا ان تعدلوا بين
النساء ولو حرصت
فلا تميلوا كل الميل فتذروها
كالمعلقه وان تصلحوا وتتقوا فان الله كان
غفورا
رحيما وان يتفرقا يغني الله كلا من سعته
وكان الله واسعا
حكيما ولله ما في السماوات وما في الارض
ولقد وصي الذين اوتوا الكتاب من قبلكم
واياكم ان اتقوا
الله وان تكفروا فان لله ما في السماوات
وما في الارض وكان الله غنيا
حميدا ولله ما في السماوات وما في الارض
وكفى بالله
وكيلا ان يشا يذهبكم ايها الناس ويات
اخرين وكان الله على ذلك
قديرا من كان يريد ثواب الدنيا
فعند الله ثواب الدنيا
والاخره وكان الله سميعا
بصيرا الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
يا ايها الذين امنوا كونوا قوامين بالقسط
شهداء لله ولو على انفسكم او الوالدين
والاقربين ان يكن غنيا او فقيرا فالله
اولى
بهما فلا تتبعوا الهوى ان تعدلوا وان
تلووا او تعرضوا فان الله كان بما تعملون
خبي
يا ايها الذين امنوا امنوا بالله ورسوله
والكتاب الذي نزل على رسوله والكتاب الذي
انزل من قبل ومن يكفر بالله
وملائكته وكتبه ورسله واليوم الاخر فقد ضل
ضلالا
بعيدا ان الذين امنوا ثم كفروا ثم امنوا
ثم كفروا ثم ازدادوا كفرا لم يكن الله
ليغفر لهم ولا ليهديهم
سبيلا بشر المنافقين بان لهم عذابا
اليما الذين يتخذون الكافرين
اولياء من دون
المؤمنين ايبتغون
عندهم العزه ان العزه لله
جميعا وقد نزل عليكم في الكتاب ان اذا
سمعتم ايات الله يكفر بها ويستهزا بها فلا
تقعدوا
معهم فلا تقعدوا معهم حتى يخوضوا في حديث
غيره انكم اذا
مثلهم ان الله جامع المنافقين والكافرين
في في جهنم
جميعا الذين يتربصون بكم فان كان لكم فتح
من الله قالوا الم نكن معكم وان كان
للكافرين نصيب قالوا الم نستحوذ عليكم
ونمنعكم من
المؤمنين فالله يحكم بينكم يوم
القيامه للن يجعل الله للكافرين على
المؤمنين
سبيلا ان المنافقين يخادعون الله وهو
خادعهم واذا قاموا الى الصلاه قاموا قسى
لا يراؤون
الناس ولا يذكرون الله الا
قليلا مذبذبين بين ذلك لا اله هؤلاء ولا
اله
ء ومن يضلل الله فلن تجد له
سبيلا يا ايها الذين امنوا لا تتخذوا
الكافرين
اولياء من دون
المؤمنين اتريدون ان تجعلوا لله عليكم
سلطانا
مبينا ان المنافقين في الدرك الاسفل من
النار ولن تجد لهم
نصيرا الا الذين تابوا الا الذين تابوا
واصلحوا واعتصموا بالله واخلصوا دينهم لله
فاولئك مع
المؤمنين وسوف يؤتي الله المؤمنين اجرا
عظيما ما يفعل الله بعذابكم ان شكرتم
وامنتم وكان الله شاكرا
عليما الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
اف
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العال
الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين سبح اسم ربك اعلى الذي خلق فسوى
والذي قدر فهدى والذي اخرج المرعى فجعله
غثاء احوى سنقرئك فلا
تنسى الا ما شاء الله انه يعلم الجهر وما
يخفى ونيسرك
لليسرى فذكر ان نفعت الذكرى
سيذكر من يخشى
ويتجنبها الاشقى الذي يصلى النار
الكبرى ثم لا يموت فيها ولا يحيا قد افلح
من تزكى وذكر اسم ربه
فصلى بل تؤثرون الحياه الدنيا والاخره خير
وابقى ان هذا في الصحف الاولى صحف ابراهيم
وموسى الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قل يا ايها
الكافرون لا اعبد ما
تعبدون ولا انتم عابدون ما اعبد ولا انا
عابد ما عبدتم ولا انتم عابدون ما اعبد
لكم دينكم ولي
دين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه
الله الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قل هو الله احد الله الصمد لم يلد
ولم يولد ولم يكن له كفوا
احد الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده اللهم اهدنا في من هديت وعافنا في من
عافيت و و لنا في من توليت وبارك اللهم
لنا فيما اعطيت وقنا واصرف عنا برحمتك شر
ما قضيت انك سبحانك تقضي بالحق ولا يقضى
عليك انه لا يذل من واليت ولا يعز من
عاديت تباركت ربنا
وتعاليت نستغفرك اللهم من كل ذنب وخطيئه
ونتوب اليك ونؤمن بك و وكل عليك ونكل اليك
الامر
كله اللهم اقسم لنا من خشيتك ما تحول به
بيننا وبين معصيتك ومن طاعتك ما تبلغنا به
جنتك ومن اليقين ما تهون به علينا مصائب
الدنيا ومتعنا اللهم باسماعنا وابصارنا
وقواتنا ابدا ما ابقيت واجعله وارث منا
واجعل ثارنا على من ظلمنا وانصرنا على من
عادانا ولا تجعل مصيبتنا في
ديننا ولا تجعل الدنيا اكبر همنا ولا مبلغ
علمنا ولا تجعل الى النار مصيرنا واجعل
الجنه هي دارنا
وقرارنا اللهم انا نسالك من الخير كله
عاجله و اجله ما علمنا منه وما لم نعلم
ونعوذ بك من الشر كله عاجله واجله ما
علمنا منه وما لم نعلم اللهم انا نسالك من
خير ما سالك به عبدك ونبيك محمد ونعوذ بك
من شر ما استعاذ منه عبدك ونبيك
محمد الله ربنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي
الاخره حسنه وقنا عذاب النار وادخلنا
الجنه مع الابرار برحمتك يا عزيز يا غفار
ربنا اننا ظلمنا انفسنا ظلما كثيرا ولا
يغفر الذنوب الا انت فاغفر لنا مغفره من
عندك وارحمنا انك انت الغفور
الرحيم اللهم اعتق رقابنا من النا
اللهم اعتق رقابنا من النار اللهم اعتق
رقابنا من النار برحمتك يا عزيز يا غفار
سبحان ربك رب العزه عما يصفون وسلام على
المرسلين والحمد لله رب العالمين وصل
اللهم وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى اله وصحبه
اجمعين الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
ان